let us pray merciful God be present in
our speaking and in our hearing may the
meditations of our hearts feed this
church and feed your world amen our
bodies specifically our bowels
compassion bravery love donuts and the
longing for wholeness these are some of
the essential elements of our walk on
this earth bodies bowels compassion
bravery love doughnuts longing I'm going
to tell you a story a story that might
initially make you slightly
uncomfortable but hang in there comic
relief takes over in the end in 2001
while I was serving as chaplain at Johns
Hopkins University in Baltimore I was
newly diagnosed with a kind of cancer
called Hodgkin's lymphoma the diagnosis
was confirmed in early februari of that
year and I had made the decision to not
make a secret out of it with any of my
students or my colleagues at the
University some colleagues had
graciously agreed to tell the news to
various student constituencies and I was
still feeling pretty emotionally fragile
when I told people so that was a big
help I was ok once they knew it was the
telling of it over and over again and
then of course all the questions that
sometimes sent me reeling I had decided
though that I would tell the campus
ministers all together at our monthly
meeting the only one of them who really
knew the complete story before then was
my closest friend in that group an
Orthodox rabbi named Joseph cats I began
the meeting with the brief heads up that
i was going
share something painful and serious with
them and then I proceeded to give them
the details I was actually feeling
pretty strong enough beat that
particular morning having it last wrap
my brain around all that was to come and
the immediate future I had confronted
and to a degree accepted that months of
chemo radiation and fatigue were about
to happen I had named at least to myself
the two heaviest burdens were going to
be the feeling of isolation brought on
by my illness and the constant worry
about my children's well-being through
it all as I described what lay ahead for
me this group made up of nearly all male
clergy did something that looked almost
as if it had been scripted they each
began to tilt their heads from one side
to the other each of them was bearing
the exact same expression of concern and
compassion on their faces as they leaned
this way or that I suddenly became
overcome with fear their expressions
made this whole ordeal real once again
that was what had been happening in the
last few weeks I would experience
pockets of calm and personal strength
and then it would all fly away in a
split second as someone would reflect
back to me my own fear either through
their words or their expressions looking
at them I was terrified I thought this
must be serious look at them I burst
into tears and tried my hardest to make
it through the remainder of their
questions not to mention the meeting it
was awful but i muscled my way through
it when it was over rabbi katz and
another colleague stayed behind to sit
with me a bit and we broke into the
kosher doughnuts I looked at them both
and said jeez you guys were killing me
this morning they didn't understand what
I meant I explained to them about what
it was like to have their collective can
reflected back to me in unison by a
bunch of guys in black I told them that
I might never tilt my head again when
someone is sharing a difficult story or
circumstance with me we all had a good
laugh about it and with my appetite
restored finished off the donuts I tell
this story because I experienced a kind
of healing men this loving group of
colleagues and ministry ached for me
they couldn't take away what was to be
but they could offer compassion love
very few words thank goodness and donuts
they could touch the hurt because I
could not hide it or myself from them
healings are not just about visceral
pain or visible hurt healing is what we
cannot see but we hunger the most for
healing brings us to a peaceable place
where we are accepted loved restored a
place where we feel again whole today we
hear of this third healing in Mark's
Gospel and Jesus tone is a bit
unsettling and we're left to ponder it
of course he is angry at the injustice
of leprosy and it separates and isolates
people and he is angry with the
interpretation of the law that requires
a statement of cleanliness and then why
doesn't he want the healed man to tell
anyone or does he this messianic secret
as it is known has us a bit puzzled the
story is a short one yet the meaning is
expansive the leper is bearing witness
to the compassion of Jesus this is a
kind of compassion that is stoked by a
fire that sees the injustice in the
lepers isolation this is the kind of
compassion that is risky for Jesus
things won't be the same for him
sure he heals this man he puts himself
at risk by even touching him he will
certainly be force further to the edges
of society the text says moved with pity
Jesus stretched out his hand and touched
him from what we know of Jesus in these
miracle stories how could he not once
again take the risk pushing the
boundaries of what is normal and
accepted in society was indeed his usual
mo some of the scholars tell us that the
word is actually not pity in the
original Greek text the word is Splunk
neatza my and the translation is closer
to moved by compassion or to be moved at
one's own depths I would put it moved
and ones gut in fact the lexicon tells
us that spike needs oh my means to be
moved as to one's bowels hence to be
moved with compassion the bowels were
thought of to be the very seat of love
and pity it all lived here in one's gut
Jesus had a gut reaction inspired by
Elijah's nudge of meinen in our first
reading from Kings to have a role in his
own healing cleanse himself in the
Jordan to be transformed so I wonder now
about our own gut reactions our own role
in healing we must get ourselves to the
river the reparative work that the world
around us sorely needs is the call made
to each one of us to care to hold to
nurture one another through our hearts
pains and sorrows we are here to heal
one another our pastors can guide us at
times they even hold us up
but the work of restoration must come
out of our own hands we must respond
starting from our gut this is the work
of a church rooted in loving compassion
that is bravely shared our bodies our
bowels compassion bravery love doughnuts
longing these are foundational
attributes that sustain our Christian
community mark presses us to see the
compassion of Jesus not merely as a
matter of temperament but also as a
discipleship orientation isn't that in
fact as believing people what we are
called to do to break down barriers all
of them religious social economic
political between human need and God's
liberating mercy illness scary illness
though not only a metaphor can be
thought of as such if we go a bit deeper
here our world is ill the span between
those who have so much Viet power or
money and those who have so little grows
wider every day we can only think of the
agony and human suffering in the Horn of
Africa and small bits because it's so
much bigger than we can possibly absorb
we feel helpless to heal it the
political climate in this country is
more than many can stomach it's hard to
find a refreshing restorative glimmer of
truth in the midst of soundbites
salacious statements and behavior that
only seems geared for a 20 second camera
clip the competition for who holds the
moral high ground feels more like
manipulative rhetoric than any actual
prophetic voice even on our own campus
we struggle to really see one another
beyond our particular barriers that seem
to mark achievement
in certain ways if we show weakness if
we are ill and our bodies are in our
hearts we just want it to go away we do
not want to confront it be informed by
it lest we lose ground I often listen to
students who find themselves physically
ill or emotionally broken and they are
frightened of what that means here in
this place of such fast paced days and
never-ending demands I don't have time
for this they say emphatically I tell
them that they are about to get their
real education they hate hearing that
this is not good news it is not going to
help them as they try to keep up or get
ahead of their peers and yet and yet
they are so very wrong our broken
moments are very brokenness itself
allows for us to face our worst fears of
isolation of not measuring up we feel
weak and yet there is God breaking
through with compassion and an extended
hand made real through the divine union
or longing that we have and God's
ever-present response to us theologian
and ulanov writes this task confronts
all of us to deal with what touches us
and not avoid it to collect our missing
parts the neglected and overlooked and
banished parts of our inner and outer
populations we are never touched in the
abstract only in the flesh the marks of
our own frown lines are sleepless nights
our neighborhood crime are neglected
land or polluted air revealed this truth
God waits in those parts waits for us to
visit the part left in the prison of
repression waits for us to offer some
life-giving water to outcast sexual
parts to give food
to starving parts all these bits must be
gathered in and nourished as Lady Julian
of Norwich puts it all must be knit in
must be one with God bodies bowels
compassion bravery love longing
doughnuts Jesus instructs the leopard to
not tell anyone some write that Jesus
knows that this news will alter his
plans so that he will have to go off by
himself to hide from hordes of ill
people who will quite naturally want to
be healed I wonder though if he isn't
telling the lepers something else is he
saying this miracle is not about me it's
about you you are the gift you are God's
own and you belong again your story
makes you you are treasure show the
priest you are transformational as
someone who has battled too serious
illnesses over the course of the last 11
years I can tell you that the urge to go
out and be part of the world again after
a period of physical social and
emotional isolation is very strong when
one first becomes ill it is often the
case that you feel as though you're
pulled in a direction that you are
compelled to resist with a strong and
certain urgency your good sense tells
you that you are sick and in need of
help that you must enter into another
kind of world that feels set apart from
the rest of us the world of the sick one
can only resist for so long until again
good sense and biology makes it clearer
that sheer will cannot suppress illness
I can completely understand the leper
who will not heed Jesus request to not
tell anyone of his healing he is elated
because he is free did he tell because
he hopes the priest would spread the
word about Jesus or did he tell to
rejoice with gratitude in his good
fortune his second chance at life and
rejoin a world whose laws had previously
tossed him aside how could he not share
his joy his gratitude this is in fact
what we all must do we are all broken in
some way be it physical emotional social
spiritual today in this very liturgy we
will anoint one another let us look to
each other with restored eyes with deep
compassion and love let us feel it in
our gut the pain of the world let us be
healers for indeed Jesus taught us how
my sisters and brothers God's own hand
is in this moment knowing that we need
that touch to be made whole we will be
transformed and as such can only be
grateful as the psalmist writes here O
Lord and be gracious to me O Lord be my
helper you have turned my mourning into
dancing you have taken off my sackcloth
and clothed me with joy so that my soul
may praise you and may not be silent o
Lord my God I will give thanks to you
forever my sisters and brothers for this
we cannot help but say Amen